[Laughter]
everyone knows actors and actresses deal
with the stress of hair and makeup on
set but did you ever think that their
on-screen makeup and prosthetics
might be taking a toll on them anyone
who wears makeup knows just how annoying
putting it on and taking it all off
again can be
but wait till you see the painstaking
process that these 15 actors were put
through
in their makeup transformations to make
you feel truly grateful for your own
makeup routine stick around to see how
these actors and actresses dealt with
these sticky makeovers
after 20 different makeup tests to find
the perfect shade of blue for jennifer
lawrence's character mystique
the process of completing this actress's
makeup for the x-men film
was already proving to be challenging
can you believe it took six girls seven
hours to fully paint the actress's body
every woman knows
is our dream come true in order to keep
herself up and adam during the
application process
lawrence would either stand or work out
on a bicycle to keep her blood pumping
not only was lawrence's full blue
bodysuit of makeup
arduous to get on but it was painful to
keep on
as the actress reported the blue paint
to be irritating to her skin
causing boils and blisters to her
complexion apparently they've simplified
the bluing of you turns out they never
had to do eight hours of full-blown body
paint ever
as much as the prosthetics used on anya
chalatra may have added to her role on
the set of the witcher
the very same prosthetics that enhanced
her acting abilities
also caused her physical harm and the
costume and the blood
and the sweat after being fitted with a
hunchback to make her character that
much more believable
the star fell victim to a pulled nerve
causing her lots of pain
the thickness of her costume caused even
more sweaty discomfort that the actress
had to deal with during her time on set
she even said i have a trap nerve in my
back that i had to get massaged out
after playing her for so long
it was very uncomfortable not much for
this beast
[Music]
from a full-blown head cast to hours of
makeup it's no wonder anne hathaway
needed to vent about her makeup
experience for the witch's movie
she took to instagram and called her
makeup look her resting witch face
after sitting through having her whole
head enveloped in
whatever that is in order to mold her
facial prosthetics
hathaway must have needed to take a
well-deserved breather from her makeup
process
if you notice you know in the length of
the video because it's a time lapse i
got stuck
ryan reynolds painful makeup application
for his character deadpool was truly
grueling because of the time that went
into the look
reynolds was a good sport maybe even too
good of a sport
as he pranked his makeup artist by
ripping off his facial prosthetics after
hours of application i'm not gonna do it
right you know there's no
point in doing it at all during john
reese davey's startling transformation
into gimli
the actor had to face terrible makeup
processes which left him barely able to
see and made his skin break out in an
allergic reaction
the lord of the rings actor had to work
on alternate days in order to give his
skin a break from the harsh makeup
process
you can't really see my brows moving or
the rest of it
in order to transform lead actor jacob
tremblay into a boy with the genetic
disorder treacher collins syndrome
makeup artists needed full body
prosthetics to make it work
the makeup itself took an hour and a
half of painfully meticulous application
and suited jacob up in a full head of
prosthetics no way is it comfortable
wearing a fake face and head for nine
whole hours of shooting it was like
there was a nice cozy warm cocoon around
your head
game of thrones is known for its
creative and interesting character
design
kai alexander's role as leaf was no
exception to this imaginative creativity
the most painful thing about this
makeover process was definitely its run
time
as kai had to sit for nearly 10 hours to
get this makeup on and
ready for the spotlight i sat in a chair
for 10 hours
top to bottom this not very well known
actress
has had an even less well-known
transformation into pepper from american
horror story asylum
the makeup look that transformed her
into pepper takes about three hours and
two makeup artists
including blinding her in one eye with a
contact lens and setting her up with a
pair of fake teeth
imagine sitting in makeup for three
hours and then having to walk around
half blind afterwards how uncomfortable
i want pbi
the most uncomfortable part of
vladimir's transformation into the night
king in the game of thrones series
has to be the six and a half you heard
me six and a half
hours of sitting in the makeup chair
then once in full night king garb
the actor had to remember not to blink
while in character
the combo of painstaking makeup
application and these intense stage
directions
definitely made for an uncomfortable
experience on the game of thrones set
it looks like easy but
it's definitely not so easy
another leading woman who had to deal
with the absolute torture of full body
makeup application
is zoe saldana in her role as gamora in
guardians of the galaxy
just like jlaw she had to deal with the
trials and tribulations of many color
tests to get her to be the perfect shade
of green
the marvel franchise star revealed just
how long it took to apply all of her
makeup
over three hours and with the help of
two separate makeup artists
zoe is quoted saying the whole coming
together of gamora every morning
that was a little grueling famous
actress haley berry played six different
characters in cloud atlas
so it's surprising that you may have
never even seen it her makeup
transformation into six different
identities was
surely an uncomfortable hassle as the
actress also had to deal with a recently
broken foot on set
her makeup artist jeremy woodhead is
quoted saying even with all the
discomfort she was going through
it was necessary to the story of each
character
that part was thrilling as an actor and
a huge challenge
one of the most well-known makeup movie
jobs in history has also been one of the
most uncomfortable
when transforming into the grinch jim
carrey is known for being irritated by
yellow contact lenses
being restrained by his full bodysuit
and needing the help of a torture
specialist to get through the movie
shoot it was when i did the grinch i was
uh
literally the makeup was like being
buried alive every day who knew that
beauty as pain
would end up being the perfect way to
describe the costumes featured in some
of your favorite movies
when you think of big blockbuster films
like the avengers maleficent and
twilight their eye-catching costumes
probably come to mind
but what price do the actors have to pay
in order to look that stunning on screen
i lost control again from eight layers
of body paint and spandex suits that
just aren't flattering
all the way to 85 pound costumes that
just make it
impossible to move you'd be surprised at
how many actors were this
close to hanging up their costumes for
good in this video we'll be taking you
through some of the most
uncomfortable costumes of all time how
much would you endure to be the star of
a hollywood film
you'd think that the breathability of a
costume would be one of the first things
that designers cross off their checklist
but that
wasn't the case for gal gadot it was so
tight and i literally
could not breathe her wonder woman suit
was so fitted that she reportedly almost
passed out from lack of oxygen right
before i passed out
they noticed that i was breathing quite
heavily luckily they eventually got the
costume sorted out so she could be
comfortable
and a strong independent woman all at
the same time
speaking of hero suits that were just a
little too tight
tom holland spent his days on set in his
spiderman costume
planning bathroom breaks 45 minutes in
advance
it looks amazing it feels terrible if
the tightness of the suit wasn't enough
tom also had to wear a thong underneath
the suit which probably wasn't the most
pleasant experience
even eating was difficult for the actor
he would have to pop out the eye hole of
his mask
and feed a straw to his mouth just to
get a sip of water
tom holland wasn't the only spider-man
who couldn't get behind his super suit
andrew garfield just couldn't get
comfortable with his second skin
the costume made him so self-conscious
and so uncomfortable that he would hide
from paparazzi on set in la
and hathaway went from being princess of
genovia to prowling around as catwoman
herself
but being a superhero on screen wasn't
all it was cut out to be for this
actress
she called her costume a psychological
terrorist that completely changed her
life
her suit made her feel as if she had to
spend the entire year of filming
working out in the gym but you could
never tell she was uncomfortable
in the actual film this might be a shock
to you but it actually took a lot of
work to turn matthew lewis into neville
longbottom
he was forced to wear an uncomfortable
fat suit in the early harry potter
movies that really messed with his body
image
he also donned fake teeth and had his
ears pushed out to him
the whole situation was pretty grim and
he even feared they would recast him
when he lost weight later on
ryan reynolds would probably tell you
the big red body
he had to wear while filming deadpool is
the worst costume anyone's had to endure
he complained on multiple occasions that
there was just no room to breathe or to
move in his outfit and it was just
overall
uncomfortable it didn't stop him from
slipping on the second skin for a sequel
though
margot robbie had a non-traditional
outfit for her hero film but it doesn't
mean she wasn't
just as uncomfortable you're probably
thinking but it's just a pair of shorts
and a shirt
well margot explained just why it made
her so uncomfortable
i'm eating burgers at lunchtime and then
you go to do a scene where your hose
down and soaking wet in a white t-shirt
it's so clingy and you're so
self-conscious about it
she even begged the director to mix up
her outfit but they just wouldn't budge
this blazing hot suit may have looked
awesome on screen but it just wasn't
practical on set
not only was it too hot but chadwick
boseman took quite a bit of time getting
used to how restricting the black
panther suit was
he described it as suffocating and said
it closed off
every possibility of air getting to you
wakanda might be forever but chadwick
wanted out of that suit as soon as he
put it on
iron man didn't just carry the avengers
on his shoulders not only was robert
downey jr's iron man suit
uncomfortable and pinchy it weighed
nearly 100 pounds
imagine adding an extra 100 pounds to
your daily wardrobe
and being expected to do your job
perfectly luckily in the later movies
they moved to cgi
and now robert only has to wear a helmet
and gloves on top of his motion capture
suit
scarlett johansson wasn't just
uncomfortable in her black widow get up
but the suit
actually sent her to the doctor's office
as she describes it the torture chamber
was so hot and sweaty that it gave her
skin conditions on multiple occasions
so that stuff is a little bit difficult
to pick up
apparently she was constantly sending
photos of her skiing to her
dermatologist
in los angeles unlike a lot of his
superhero friends it wasn't the suit
that made filming unpleasant for chris
evans
it was his helmet apparently every time
he put it on he immediately got a
headache
according to his co-star jeremy renner
he was the worst off when it came to
getting an uncomfortable costume
the thing gave him a migraine it hit
weird pressure points
mark ruffalo might be the most epic
green hero you've ever seen on screen
but behind the scenes looked a lot
different mark ruffalo's costume was
actually just a motion capture suit that
brought him quite a bit of embarrassment
and humiliation
he even called his outfit ridiculous
pajamas that made me look like a chinese
checkerboard
if you know star wars you know leia's
golden bikini she was forced to wear in
return of the jedi
well maybe it shouldn't be as iconic as
it is carrie fisher absolutely hated the
costume
and not just because it was
uncomfortable or because she was
constantly
checking for any bounce or slip after
takes she hated that it made her into a
provocative figure
something she never wanted to be vision
has no problem
transforming into a 50s tv husband but
things weren't quite so easy for paul
bettany and wandavision's makeup
department
disney's new series easily zips between
decades
but a lot of genius costume makeup and
set design went into recreating famous
sitcoms and giving them the perfect mcu
twist
you won't believe the colors the team
had to use to film those black and white
scenes
vision had to take on an entirely new
hue i'm sorry
here's the wardrobe and makeup magic
that went on behind the scenes
paul bettany had to wear vision makeup
six days a week
and although he says it wasn't difficult
to put on taking it off was an entirely
different story
it took more than an hour to remove the
makeup and the actor described it as
feeling like his skin was in
tatters to try and save his skin betany
started spending 20 minutes in a mobile
sauna
every day after filming it loosened the
makeup
and allowed it to be peeled off without
taking any of his skin with it
and it's a pretty relaxing way to
decompress after work
that pain will roll over the earth
seeing the black and white sets in color
makes us realize just how much work went
into making those grayscale scenes
pop on our tv lots of blues and purples
were used to get the hues to look just
right
costume designer mayas rubeo even took
pictures of potential outfits using the
black and white filter on her phone to
see how they'd look on screen
this also meant that vision's red skin
had to go
because it showed up way too dark on
film instead
they painted his face blue to achieve
the right contrast
well we could rather do that catherine
hahn brings the perfect amount of wit
and mystery to the character of agnes
hello dear i'm
agnes your neighbor to the right but
filming the black and white scenes were
hard for her
and the rest of the cast for a
surprising reason
it was way too hot on set the show used
lighting techniques that were accurate
for the era
but they were also extremely warm pair
that with the thick costumes and live
studio audience
and han was spending most of the episode
trying not to sweat through her dress
but despite the heat filming the 50
scenes ended up being one of her
favorite onset memories
do you set your jelliester with all of
these fashion transformations
it was also important for the actors to
learn how to properly wear the clothes
we don't mean how to put them on but how
to carry themselves and even speak
differently while wearing them
elizabeth olsen opened up about how
challenging it was to capture the
personalities of women
in those specific eras through their
fashion from the more restrictive style
in the 50s
to the more relaxed vibe of the 70s the
cast even attended a sitcom boot camp
where they learned how to walk talk and
act like retro characters
really try to make everything very error
specific
elizabeth olsen loved to collaborate on
wanda's sitcom costumes
especially because she spent time on the
set of full house with her sisters when
she was a kid
when it comes to that iconic scarlet
witch costumes from the comics
olson was the one fighting for it to be
as comic accurate as possible
she convinced the show runners to go
full out with their halloween tribute to
the original scarlet witch
and mayas rubeo made sure all the colors
were bright and accurate
right down to comic wanda's original
pink tights
this is what our show is going to be
about for one division vision's
halloween costume received the same
attention
the green and yellow look complete with
a huge fake mind stone
is an homage to how he looked in the
avengers number 57
all the way back in 1968. there are
reasons marvel finally went for the
costumes now and not before
for one the halloween episode meant the
costumes could purposefully look cheap
and simple
and two before they didn't have the
rights to the character's original
costumes
but now that disney owns fox those
copyright issues are behind them
we can't reverse death one of maya's
rubello's favorite characters to dress
was geraldine monica
especially her groovy 70s style one of
the aspects that her and actress tiana
paris wanted to include was a natural
afro
this allowed them to represent black
culture in a typically white centric
sitcom world
to get inspired to play a sitcom version
of monica rambo
paris took cues from characters like
thelma and willowna in good times
and we can look forward to some more
interesting fashion moments from monica
in the future
rubeo promises that the character will
appear in more wild and surprising looks
before the series is through
i'm geraldine
maya's rubello designed wanda's wedding
dress herself and made it entirely from
scratch
if it looks like a familiar old
hollywood style that's because it
definitely is it pays homage to audrey
hepburn specifically her dress from
1957's funny face
vision's outfits also got to pay tribute
to some television royalty
for episode 1 rubeo took a lot of
inspiration
from the dick van dyke show and designed
a suit and tie from scratch for paul
bettany
the actor thought it was so unique and
comfortable that he wanted to take it
home after filming
excellent plan elizabeth olsen's hair
had to endure a lot of transformations
meant to resemble looks from some of the
greatest leading ladies in the history
of sitcoms
the styles are often a mix of different
eras because the aim wasn't to have them
be as accurate as possible
but rather create over-the-top styles
that fit into wanda's fantasy world
in episode 1 we see 50s curls
reminiscent of i love lucy
while episode 2 was heavily inspired by
bewitched and the mary tyler moore show
when it came to the 70s it was all about
crazy wild colors
so there was no better show to use for
inspiration than the brady bunch
the set design and wardrobe department
worked together to coordinate wallpaper
paints and fabric
that would go well together and resemble
sets of 70 sitcoms
wanda's look was also heavily inspired
by donna from that 70s show
especially the straight red hair by
pulling from a show that aired in the
90s
rubio and her team were able to keep
wanda's look modern
while not skimping on the outrageous 70s
fashion
it was a challenge for elizabeth olsen
to transform from superhero
to newlywed to new mom but she had
fashion that emulated famous tv moms
from the 80s to help get her into
character
her plaid prints were inspired by shows
like roseanne
while the curly messy hair is
reminiscent of family ties
olsen definitely looks frazzled but
capable and the chaotic 80s styling was
a perfect time to introduce the
character to motherhood i have
everything under control
getting all these looks right was
difficult but by focusing on prints and
silhouettes
rubeo was able to capture and modernize
the different decades of tv fashion
designs were often inspired by specific
colors or types of fabric
the dress wanda wore in the 70s was
inspired by one piece of vintage fabric
that rubeo found and knew she needed to
use
there was only 30 meters available so
she turned it into a simple dress that
could accommodate
wanda's growing belly and also perfectly
complement her hair
the result is one of the series most
iconic looks
your personal best with in-depth styling
also comes meticulous attention to every
small detail that might take us out of
the decade we're supposed to be
experiencing
the wardrobe and makeup department had
to pay attention to even the tiniest
things
like the length of the actor's
fingernails and their shape
to the different types of fake eyelashes
wanda would be wearing
the 50s showed us short clean nails and
eyelashes perfect for batting across the
dinner table
yes going from black and white to full
color
isn't just a shtick to reel in old
sitcom fans
it's also a way to represent wanda's
inner conflict of being both an avenger
and a grieving woman chasing a
picture-perfect life
this is why it was important for
wardrobe and set designers to create the
most
colorful world imaginable as soon as the
show transitions from black and white
wanda wears a lot of reds or similar
colors
and it's entirely on purpose the black
and white wanda was further distanced
from reality
but as color comes back and the story
progresses we see more of the true
scarlet
witch what gone through three hours of
makeup and then stand in front of the
mirror and see yourself transformed
for some acting in a harry potter movie
sounds like a dream come true
but when you realize how incredibly
uncomfortable some of the makeup effects
were
it might make things seem a little less
appealing
from transforming humans into gringotts
goblins
to the hours of makeup to bring
voldemort to life and even a giant body
double for hagrid
some of the most iconic harry potter
makeup transformations
were seriously painful for the actors
underneath it all
had prosthetics on before and it's like
it can be tough it can be like hard work
for the second task in the goblet of
fire harry had to eat giliweed
and grow gills so he could swim into the
black lake which you might assume would
all be done with cgi
but nope they actually did it for real
the gills were made out of silicone and
silk so that they would billow
underwater
they had to be glued onto daniel
radcliffe's neck so firmly so that they
would stay put during the long
underwater filming process and also
during the harrowing scene where he had
to swim to the surface carrying two
heavy lifelike dolls of ron and
gabrielle de la cour
in the end daniel said that he was
really proud that he made it through
good god who's that really robbie
coltrane who plays hagrid
is tall but not giant tall
in order to transform him into the half
giant hagrid they gave him risers in his
shoes
and padded him with heavy costumes extra
wigs and prosthetics to make him appear
larger but they also brought in a six
foot four body double for wide shots
who had to wear some massive padding and
a prosthetic animatronic hagrid head
because the costume was so huge and
heavy they actually attached tubes that
pumped cold water into it
so the body double didn't overheat and
pass out the embarrassment of seeing
yourself
18 feet high in front of a lot of people
you don't know in order to transform
human actors into gringotts goblins
the makeup team started their work at 4
am
they created molds of each actor's face
and created a combination of rubber
masks and individual prosthetic parts to
attach
one by one the actors also had to have
their hands covered with extensive
makeup and prosthetic pieces
long fake fingernails and dentures to
finish off the look
each goblin took four hours to get ready
and they even wore contact lenses that
obscured their vision so much
that they needed chaperones to help get
them around the set
on this one we're doing 45 full
prosthetic makeups
british actor warwick davis not only
played professor flitwick the first
goblin bank teller but
also grip hook in the harry potter
series very unusual
is it to make sure he was unrecognizable
from one character to the next
it took hours and hours in the makeup
chair first
they created a cast of his face which
involved sitting under layers of
silicone and plaster for
hours and only his nose holes free to
breathe
once the prosthetic pieces for grip hook
were applied warwick said he had to
re-learn how to use his face
underneath all those extra layers and
totally adjust his voice
to speak through the false teeth
ready for the office in order to make
the actor who played dumbledore's
brother aberforth
look as much like michael gambin as
possible they used a lot of makeup and
extensive wigs
the makeup crew added silicone to his
forehead and face to push back his
hairline
applied prosthetic bags under his eyes
completely changed his eyebrows
and of course added his long hair and
beard to finish off the look
it was quite interesting because in a
way you're working on a
blank canvas even though you might think
it was cgi
the scene in which harry accidentally
blows up his aunt marge
was all done in camera it took 20 people
to build and apply the inflatable suit
to pam ferris
the actress who played ant marge and
included pumps
degassing chambers and inflatable
bladders
they even created a balloon shaped and
painted like her face
attached it to her body and pumped it
full of air to give the effect of her
face inflating
to film professor lupin turning into a
werewolf they created each step of the
transformation on the actor david thulis
with prosthetic makeup
before adding cgi in post the makeup
team
wanted to avoid the cliche werewolf
transformation
so they focused on changing his eyes and
bringing out the two huge scars across
his face with makeup and silicone
each step of the transformation took six
hours to complete
and they actually built fake moving body
parts that were attached to david so
they could capture as much as possible
in camera
that turned out not to be practical much
to my relief because it looked really
very uncomfortable to do that when it
came to peter pettigrew
the makeup team tried hard to connect
the human version of pettigrew to
scabbers the rat through his hair skin
texture and hands
the actor sat for hours in the makeup
chair as they added the grey
balding wig browning teeth dirty pointy
nails
and skin texture until he was almost
entirely covered in makeup
and itchy fake hair it's a horrible
profession
but i think you should be an actor even
though we might not realize it
lucius malfoy undergoes a serious change
over the course of the harry potter
movies
the actor said he went from a simple
natural look and wig application
to a lot more time in the makeup trailer
they added prosthetic bags under his
eyes
and very heavy pale makeup to make him
look as tired and unhealthy as the
character needed to be
the eighth film has become a shadow of
his former self if paulie juice potion
were a real thing
it would be much easier than what
brendan gleeson went through to become
mad i moody
they spent hours adding an entire layer
of skin
over his real face to build the eye and
its holder into
in order to make it look like it was
embedded in his face
they covered his real eye in tape and
added the bulging glass eye over it
so for the entire shoot he could only
see out of one eye
the magical eye was radio controlled by
a crew member who made it swivel around
but
sometimes it would actually pop out
sponge the transfers onto my scalp and
seeing voldemort for the first time was
a huge undertaking because of how
enormous the fans expectations were for
that exact moment
in order to transform the handsome ray
finds into the dark lord
they used a combination of makeup and
prosthetics
the process took hours but luckily he
only had to do the full transformation
about
60 to 70 times throughout the whole
series and about 50 of those times were
for the last two movies
rafe still wanted to be able to act
under it all so they covered his
eyebrows reshaped his eyes
added long creepy fingernails and false
teeth
but the transformation wasn't complete
until they removed his nose
using cgi sort of slightly translucent
vein like quality we all remember the
scene where harry breaks his arm playing
quidditch
and gilda roy lockhart comes along to
fix it but ends up removing all the
bones instead
well that wobbly boneless arm wasn't cgi
at all but was actually a prosthetic
that they actually attached to the real
daniel radcliffe
and guess what he still has it along
with a few pairs of potter glasses
daniel said that he has that creepy fake
arm sitting in his attic
all these years later i don't seek them
out
when creating professor trelawny emma
thompson had the idea that
since she is always looking into the
future the divination teacher can't
really see where she is in the present
so they came up with her famous coke
bottle glasses
while they were perfect for making her
eyes look very funny and large
they were actually quite uncomfortable
as they magnified
everything around her you must look
beyond
for the enormous battle at hogwarts the
makeup team worked overtime to apply
fake blood and wounds to the literally
hundreds of actors and background
performers
playing the students and members of
dumbledore's army the actors
especially matthew lewis who played
neville longbottom had to wear itchy
uncomfortable fake blood and silicone
prosthetic wounds for
days on end during filming which got
very tiresome in the end
which was great to start with you know
blood and cuts and bruises
and it takes like two hours to transform
the very young
very famous actors into older versions
of themselves
it required lots of prosthetics and
makeup but
not too much according to the crew the
first
old age test made ron look about 75
years old and
seriously unhealthy eventually they
found a good balance
did it work well that's for you to
decide
what's the matter baby you don't think i
look pretty like this
have you ever been wowed by an actor's
on-screen transformation
with cgi there's not much we can't bring
to screens today
but some productions still opt to use
classic makeup and prosthetics to bring
characters to life
for good reason check out these epic
makeup transformations you won't believe
kristen stewart played bella swan as
both an ordinary human
and a lethal vampire but in between
those two states they had to make it
seem like kristen stewart shed 30 pounds
while pregnant with renesme in breaking
dawn part 1
the makeup department had their work cut
out for them when it came to kristin
she had to wear prosthetics on her
cheekbones collarbones and chin to give
her face that sunken effect
the rest of her body was all done with
cgi but who would have thought her face
was all done with makeup
for a human i can't imagine that it gets
any better than that
because of how intense pennywise looks
in the it films a lot of people probably
don't even know who the actor is behind
the killer clown
well his name is bill skarsgard and he
looks nothing like his character
his absurd looking clown costume was
also done with makeup and prosthetics
come on how is that even possible
georgie meet pennywise jacob tremblay is
the next brad pitt of hollywood and you
can't convince us otherwise
just look at his performance in the film
wonder as auggie
literally phenomenal but it wasn't just
his acting that brought the character to
life
the makeup team worked themselves to the
bone applying prosthetics and makeup in
order to showcase auggie's facial
differences
he even had to wear a neck and face
piece to bring it all together
bad days do people avoid touching you
it couldn't have been easy for ross
marquan to keep still while he got his
makeup on for red skull
just look at how many layers of
prosthetics went into his transformation
and how exactly did they get the
prosthetics to contour like that
we're kind of jealous if they shoot down
one plane hundreds more will rain
fire upon them oscar isaac
everyone recognizes him as the beloved
poe but he was extremely unrecognizable
in his role as en sabanur in x-men
apocalypse
he had so much prosthetic and makeup on
that you probably wouldn't have made the
connection to oscar when you saw the
character on screen
oscar claims it was so intense he
couldn't even move his head
and at the end of the day the makeup
literally had to be scraped off of him
i know you can hear me okay we for sure
thought this one had to be cgi but we
were wrong
idris elba joins this list of actors
because he spent hours every day getting
prosthetics glued on
in the end it gave us the character
crawl in star trek beyond so we're not
complaining
please someone give these makeup artists
more credit
arnold schwarzenegger's famous line i'll
be back
made the terminator epic and so did the
makeup department
prosthetics and details were used to
give him that peeled back robot look
underneath his skin in fact the makeup
was so specific that the makeup team and
the camera operators teamed up and
figured out the angles that the makeup
would look best during filming
leonardo dicaprio gave everything he had
when it came to playing hugh glass in
the revenant
he literally fought a bear but the
special effects team also had a huge
role in this oscar-winning movie
his realistic wounds and even his
dislocated ankle were all
achieved using prosthetics and makeup
not cgi
no he won't he's afraid
robert england's transformation into
freddy krueger was revolutionary for its
time
the makeup was phenomenal and as the
years went by and more films continued
to come out the makeup only got better
it was all thanks to prosthetics and a
very talented special effects team
bring me more mike myers is hilarious
and so is his character the cat in the
hat
his costume process was super similar to
jim carrey's for the grinch
maybe just a little less intense instead
of cgi
they decided to keep it real they used
actual human hair to glue to his face
and the rest was makeup and prosthetics
they even had to use magnets to keep
everything together
let's take a look under the hood because
when you got a corset on my waist was
about 20 inches and you absolutely can't
breathe
sailing the high seas and getting into
swashbuckling pirate fights
may seem like a good time but
transforming yourself into the look of a
pirate can be less than desirable
to convincingly create scenes that take
place in the 1700s
it was vital that all the actors who
appeared on screen
look the part the application of makeup
and prosthetics on an actor can be a
long and grueling process
the complex makeup and costumes worn by
actors can cause extreme discomfort
pain and in some cases physical injuries
which actors experience the most pain
and discomfort due to their makeup
and costumes skarsgard's bootstrap bill
turner had the unique distinction of
being the only member of davy jones crew
who wasn't computer generated however
that may not be as cool as it sounds
skarsgard had to undergo a grueling
makeup process
spending four hours in the chair to
achieve his rotting ship
look and was dubbed bulabase on set
because of the appearance
he said that they couldn't shoot for
more than three days straight because he
would get rashes from the makeup
and when he was done filming for the day
it took an additional hour and a half to
remove the heavy makeup and prosthetics
which wasn't too gentle on the skin we
applaud skarsgard for his commitment to
the role
and even though it sounds painful the
makeup looks great
captain salazar and his crew are some of
the coolest looking beings in the
pirates franchise
and while cgi had a big part in making
that look possible
practical effects were also a major part
in creating the effect
the makeup team went with a cracked
earth look for all the skin on the
cursed pirates
using prosthetics and paints javier
bardem
spent three and a half hours every day
in a chair
getting his makeup and prosthetics done
which became a very repetitive and
tedious process
bardem also had dots and some blue
screen on his face to help the animators
in post
the end result is a truly awesome effect
and all the time that went into making
it
was well worth it well it took me a
little
while to adjust to the time frame
hector barbosa is one of the most
memorable pirates from the franchise
and his awesome look is a big part of
that it took about an
hour and a half for jeffrey rush to get
into his full pirate makeup
this included wearing fake rotten teeth
and wearing contact
lenses to make his eyes look more dead
and yellowish
having fake teeth and contact lenses in
all the time
wasn't a comfortable situation even
though this caused rush some discomfort
the end result is a grimy sword-wielding
captain
that is probably the image a lot of
people conjure when thinking of a pirate
get back on your bloomin cockroaches
it's been 18 years since the curse of
the black pearl was released
so we'll forgive you if you forgot this
character
jacoby was one of barbosa's undead crew
members
who had a very specific physical
attribute his beard was on fire
and this wasn't a camera trick or cgi
the makeup and effects department made a
fake beard with wiring in the dreads
that were used to light incense
which actor vince lozano actually wore
while it was lit
they had to relight his beard between
takes and it's just as dangerous as it
sounds
lizano was burned several times the
beard would occasionally catch on fire
and it would also burn
other people when his beard would flip
into them you kind of always smell
burning hair around this guy
perhaps next time they should use cgi
instead
no fair rigetti is one of the most fun
and lovable characters in the series
with his signature look and fake eye
mackenzie crook
the actor behind rigetti didn't actually
have a fake eye
instead he wore multiple different types
of contact lenses while filming
soft lenses were used to give his eyes a
certain grimy look
and hard lenses were used to represent
the fake eye as the lenses physically
bulged out crook's eye
these hard lenses can be very
uncomfortable but righty didn't let that
stop him from putting on
a memorable performance hi
before elizabeth swann became the badass
fighter on the seas
she was the pristine girl who dressed in
perfect clothing
this included a corset in the first
movie which wasn't very comfortable
nightly said that being in a corset is
positively awful
and that it makes it difficult to
breathe
ironically that is the plot point used
when she is in the corset in the movie
luckily for nightly the later movies saw
her wearing more loose-fitting clothing
to adjust for the extra movement and
fighting she was doing
the pirates of the caribbean movies are
extremely large
in scale and this includes a very big
cast of extras
any time you see a pirate on screen a
ton of time and effort went into
creating the look
pirate clothes arrived new so the crew
had to weather and age them by putting
them into a cement mixer with bricks
they also dirtied the clothes which
meant actors were spending
hours in the hot sun with dirty clothes
on they had upwards of 50 makeup artists
at a time
getting the actors ready and keeping
them looking the right way throughout
the entire
shoot not the most pleasant or
comfortable experience
but it definitely sells them as real
pirates
even though the main focus is on the
pirates don't forget the townsfolk that
appear in these films
like the pirate cruise there were a ton
of townsfolk extras which required a lot
of clothing
costume designer pennyrose said for the
first film they ordered 900 pieces of
costuming for the extras
and these clothes weren't the most
comfortable to wear
some of the women had to wear tight
corsets just like keira knightley did
and some of the men had to wear tight
necker chiefs
the fittings were done on the fly as
actors were constantly swapping clothes
to get the proper fit
this made things chaotic and difficult
as there were so many extras
that it was nearly impossible to keep
track of it all
rose said the entire process was a mad
house especially since
most of it took place outside in the hot
sun but she definitely achieved the
right look
in the end johnny depp's portrayal of
captain jack sparrow is iconic
and so is his look to create the
signature look we know and love
depp had to go through a very specific
makeup and costuming process
to make sure his look remained
consistent across all
films this included a wig with
dreadlocks
his real beard braided with beads weaved
in his coat
pants boots and of course the iconic hat
what you may not know is that they
actually had multiple pairs of boots for
depth
because depp was getting wet so often
his boots would fill with water
making it difficult and uncomfortable to
walk the solution
was to create boots that could drain the
water more efficiently and the crew was
regularly switching out his boots
between takes
depp also had to wear special contact
lenses during shooting
the sunny days were so bright and
painful that he needed something to
protect his eyes
i had contact lenses made for him that
were actually sunglasses
naomi harris transformed her look to
play tia damma in dead man's chest and
at world's end
she wore a wig black lipstick black
eyeshadow tribal markings and gold and
dirt on her face
along with prosthetic teeth that would
clip in and out
she also filled her mouth with vegetable
dye before each take which meant she had
to say her lines with the dye dripping
out of her mouth
it wasn't the most comfortable
experience but it looked cool and we
appreciate everything she did for the
character
same story different versions and all
are true
to capture the amazing performance of
bill nye and transform him into davy
jones
the crew had an eye in a motion capture
suit for all of his scenes
he can be seen with white dots painted
on his face
along with some dark makeup around his
mouth and eyes
so all i had was little white dots on my
face i had to wear sad gray pajamas with
dots all over for the computers
as nye pointed out this isn't a
flattering costume and he felt left out
compared to his co-stars
sounds like his ego may have been
bruised a bit but even if he didn't look
that cool
on set he definitely looks like one of
the coolest characters in the finished
movie
speaking of being jealous of your
co-star's wardrobe
jack davenport wasn't too fond about
norington's costume
he had to wear a proper powdered white
wig which he said
i look like an ice cream and these guys
just look so
cool when he learned he was going to be
in a pirate movie
he thought he was going to have the
chance to dress up and look cool
but instead he had to dress up like an
idiot
and he was not happy about it sorry
davenport
you win some you lose some that is
without doubt the worst pirate i have
ever seen kind of enjoyed wallowing in
it it was
helpful um sort of self-inflicted pain
disney characters look effortlessly
ethereal but working 16-hour days
in tight costumes with thick prosthetics
isn't exactly a magical experience
behind the scenes there were fake faces
complicated contacts and some of the
most restrictive corsets
in the world you might see these live
action scenes differently once you know
how these actors
really felt after being poked and
prodded into fairy tale perfection
once you put those things on you feel
like cruella de vil
emma stone had 47 looks to wear in the
upcoming cruella movie
she even had to let makeup artists
graffiti her face
but the most challenging outfits for
emma were those which had
super long trains particularly the
garbage truck dress which had a train
that was
40 feet long it's like things you only
ever imagined and think you would
actually put on your body
and carry behind you on a garbage truck
she couldn't even move with it on so the
train had to be added to the dress
after emma climbed on the back of the
truck a scene we'll have to wait to see
in the movie if we want to know how well
she actually
pulled it off for cruella emma stone did
a lot of climbing while wearing epic
dresses
this look with an incredibly long red
train had to be worn while the actress
climbed on top of a car
pulling the skirt around the car without
it getting caught was the hardest part
and not letting the weight of the dress
pull her to the ground
co-star emma thompson gave her props for
her skill in maneuvering the heavy dress
saying she had to put it around the car
about a million
times because it was so hard to get
right every single part
is so beautifully played to become the
beast
dan stevens had to walk around on stilts
and wear a 40-pound prosthetic muscle
suit covered with visual effects
indicators that tracked his
every movement he compared the stilts to
wearing 10 inch high heels
it's an ordeal for my calf muscles alone
thankfully he wore a cooling unit under
his suit that could be plugged in
between takes so he didn't overheat
what a regrettably large head you have
i should very much like to head it it
wasn't just
cgi that made the red queen's head huge
in alice in wonderland helena bottom
carter
also had a prosthetic forehead applied
to make her head seem
larger and push back her hairline the
three-pound wig on top of her head
didn't make things any more comfortable
and costume designer colleen atwood
outfitted her with an elizabethan dress
with a high collar
the actress's head was then digitally
enhanced to appear three times its
normal size on film
but that meant helena had to be really
careful about not bringing her hands
anywhere near her head while acting
so they wouldn't interfere with the
special effects they reminded me ever so
often that my
i was much wider than i thought ever
find yourself wishing you had a pair of
cinderella's glass slippers
well you should count yourself lucky
that you don't while the original plan
was to have lily james wear the slippers
it turns out they were much too painful
and she couldn't even get them
on it doesn't fit because it's made of
frosty crystal
real ones were designed for the film but
the slippers we see the princess
actually wear are completely cgi the
fate of glass
yes turning johnny depp into the mad
hatter involved some complicated
contacts and crooked teeth
he was transformed by makeup artist
valley o'reilly
and hair stylist terry belial the orange
wig and clown-like makeup was a daunting
task
but what was most uncomfortable were
these kooky contacts the actor wore for
all his scenes but depp knew exactly
what he was signing up for since the mad
hatter's look was based on watercolors
by the actor and director
tim burton oh great one who summons me
terrible one who commands me creating
the genie for aladdin meant putting will
smith in a motion capture suit
the real uncomfortable part of this
costume wasn't that it was too stiff or
restrictive
it was that it was thin and skin tight
not leaving much to the imagination
it was done this way so they could catch
the actors angles and movements
perfectly since the genie isn't
technically wearing clothes
that is actually me it's a 100
cgi character emma watson loved belle's
yellow ball gown
but it was actually a deceivingly thick
dress to wear
it was made from multiple layers of
satin organza
to add a modern look to the gown 2160
swarovski crystals were added to the top
layer of the dress
multiple copies of the dress were
created for these scenes taking over 12
000 hours to make in total i had the big
dress on he had the ridiculous beast
finger you know we were like
it was very bonding to accommodate
aladdin's running along rooftops the
design team traded pointy toe slippers
for sturdier custom-designed ankle boots
but not every one of his outfits was
made for comfort aladdin eventually has
his prince alley makeover
and has to wear copious layers of ivory
and gold
including a long cape and an oversized
turban embellished with ostrich feathers
it was sweltering in the heat so
performing in this costume was the least
fun part of filming
no matter how good he looked did you
know that acrobatic performers have to
wear tight corsets despite all their
flips and tricks
actress eva green found that out the
hard way when she performed
many of her own aerial stunts in dumbo
she had to trade her comfortable and
flexible training outfit
for a circus outfit that was much more
restrictive and had many decorative
pieces for her
to be aware of as well as a perfectly
quaffed wig
colleen atwood designed the costumes as
circus performer accurate as possible
which meant a pretty tight stiff bodice
and i was so scared of
of heights it was real phobia and i i
really panicked at the beginning
any brunette who bleaches their hair
will know it is
not easy but for alice in wonderland
actress mia vasikovska insisted on
having her hair
really bleached to the perfect blonde
instead of just wearing a wig
she went through endless hair dyeing
sessions and touch-ups during filming
and since her hair is pinned straight
the waves had to be touched up between
almost every take the fairy godmother's
dress in cinderella
was the biggest dress created for the
movie with incredible volume that
actress helena bonham carter was
basically
swimming in so the dress was a piece of
architecture sandy powell spared no
effort designing the costume
this costume is not like the rest
actually underneath here
is a crinoline cage which actually gives
it the silhouette there are led lights
and
10 000 swarovski crystals hooked up to
it with tiny
fine wires so helena had to be
incredibly careful with
it especially while running in some of
her scenes
when it came to making maleficent fly a
pretty simple costume addition ended up
being one of the most
challenging things for angelina jolie to
wear and perform in
the wings were cgi but jolie actually
had to wear little stumps on her back so
they could digitally add the wings later
this proved a challenge because she had
to always be sure to move as if she had
huge wings protruding from her back
the most painful part of getting these
wings just right was the fork-like rig
she and other flying characters had to
be hooked up to when filming their
flight scenes
mulan's costume designer bina degler
knew exactly how she wanted to bring one
of the characters most iconic looks to
life
but it wasn't an easy outfit for actress
liu efe to perform in
there are multiple layers of robe
underdress panels and a sash that all
add drama and flow to the outfit it
nearly took four weeks to embroider and
40 feet of material
it wasn't as light and easy to move in
as it seems
so actress leo faye was tasked with
making movement in the heavy costume
look
effortless that's that might be not
everyday
everyone could experience creature actor
ed osmond had to wear a very strange
suit to become
dumbo while all we see on screen is the
incredible cgi
behind the scenes he had to wear a green
suit and crutch-like arm extensions
he was walking on all fours for about
three hours per day
proving his role in the movie was one of
the hardest to master
becoming elliot the dragon for the
live-action pete's dragon was another
daunting task that required a huge green
suit
motion capture actor eric synden had to
wear a massive
green wire mesh head so it would look
like the actors were really interacting
with the dragon
sure it was heavy and bulky but the size
also made it super easy to track and
later
alter with cgi we were able to capture
exactly what he was seeing
and we were going to be able to put that
back on the screen makeup artist and
designer denise kum was responsible for
mulan's incredible matchmaking makeup
but the look was thick
and made facial expressions challenging
each stage was layered with a mix of
pigments
fashion makeup and conventional makeup
and it was all literally painted onto
mulan's face
while mulan cuts her hair in the
animated version designing hair for the
live action version was also
much different and involved applying
tons of hair pieces to leo yaffay's hair
lily james and the live-action
cinderella were in the news a lot over
reports that her waist had been
digitally shrunk in her ball gown but in
reality it was just a very tight and
painful corset
i learned this course it's really hard
to breathe it took 20 minutes to get
lily in
and then out of the dress and corset
which took 20 people to make and
featured 10
000 swarovski crystals and three miles
of hems
princess jasmine has more than 10 outfit
changes during the film
the most painful dress naomi scott had
to wear was this royal pink number
the bodice was tight and restrictive and
it was embellished with heavy gold coins
that the actress had to be careful
not to rattle too much or catch on
anything while moving around
the most challenging costume for emily
blunt to wear as mary poppins was this
dress
while they look like they have ruffles
and fabric details it's all painted on
to blend in with the animation of the
scene
which also affected the way emily had to
wear the costumes
she had to carry them as if they did
have ruffles and voluminous skirts and
make sure her movements didn't make the
dresses fall flat
turning 2d designs into a 3d dress
you won't believe how many of these
actors didn't have any cgi used for
their mcu character
instead they had hours in a makeup chair
which actor had
such intense body makeup and prosthetics
that they literally had to sit in a
sauna so it could melt off
how about the actor who carried an extra
8 pounds of weight on their head alone
cgi magic is impressive but these
extraordinary makeup prosthetic and
costume transformations will blow you
away
when it was time to be in the makeup
chair michael b jordan spent a whole two
and a half hours
every single day having a whopping 90
individual prosthetics glued and sealed
on his body
leaving the actor totally exhausted by
the end of it what's worse is that he
was nowhere near the end of his workday
since he still
actually had to shoot as for the removal
process
well he was stuck in a sauna to help all
the prosthetics actually
sweat off there she is in all her glory
when tom hiddleston put on his loki suit
he was carrying around an extra 30
pounds
add the headpiece an extra 8 pounds
a whopping 40 extra pounds at all times
this large and heavy helmet covers
hiddleston's ears which also limit how
much he was able to actually hear
the suit itself was extremely hot and
sweaty for the actor and with the helmet
well he was facing an overwhelming icky
sweat fest every single day
hiddleston said the whole experience was
uncomfortable and left him feeling
really claustrophobic
where the first piece locks you like
that the second piece zips up and
launches like that and the third piece
is like
the new captain america is here but for
wyatt russell
it's been a long time coming he
auditioned for the role years ago
when he was cast as the new captain he
actually asked if he could wear chris
evans suit
what we see him in here in the falcon in
the winter soldier though is a new
costume made just for him
a hot stiff difficult and painful
costume
it was so bad that an old shoulder
injury of his actually flared up
part of the reason it's so uncomfortable
is because there's supposed to be a
sort of presentational effect have you
ever seen a superhero with bad posture
next time you watch the show remember
that russell is working through
loads of pain every day there's
something that's easier and something
that's harder
she looks good there's no denying that
but at what cost
well tessa thompson knows since she was
the one wearing an almost entirely
plastic outfit
definitely not comfortable or breathable
despite feeling incredibly stiff
hot and always sweating thompson managed
to act her way through it
if that weren't tough enough she also
had her fair share of wire work
discomfort on top of discomfort my
makeup goes on much faster but it's it's
like
glue there actually glue transfers it
then they stick to me
dave bautista spent the end of every
shoot day is drax in asana
not a bad gig right think again he also
had a whopping
5 hours in the makeup chair every single
day getting 18 pieces of prosthetic
attached and makeup done by
5 different makeup artists if that
weren't bad enough
bautista had to stand for the majority
of it with his arms sticking out
how he still had the energy to perform
is a total mystery to us
so how does the sauna fit into all of
this
well when he first had the makeup on
rubbing it off was so tough on his body
that it damaged his skin to the point
that he described it looking like
hamburger meat so the best solution was
to put him in a sauna so the makeup
could just
melt off elizabeth tabiki had a shorter
prep time than many of the other marvel
characters but she still spent a solid
hour and a half with two makeup artists
at work
her prep pretty much involved being
painted and allowing it to dry until she
was ready to get into what was lovingly
called the
aisha taco aka this giant metal gold
dress
while it looks regal and elegant the
costume was made almost
entirely of metal making it super heavy
for her to move and work in
dabiki described it as similar to having
a child hanging off your back
yeah not a great feeling robert downey
jr has had many costumes over the years
when he played iron man
but one thing for sure is that none of
them were enjoyable to wear
the actor said that his experience with
the costumes was so tough at times
it almost led to a personality breakdown
this suit
it's no surprise to learn it's extremely
heavy stuffy and hot
remember he doesn't just have to wear it
but perform intensely in it
i can't believe i made a whole movie
with this thing
wyatt russell may have wanted to wear
chris evans suit but it's probably for
the best that he didn't since
evans detested wearing his captain
america suit
overall it was super tight and sweaty we
can see how fitted it is here
super tough considering how much he has
to move and so athletically
the cap was confirmed to be the worst
part of the costume
not only is it kind of awkward looking
it was also super tight and
uncomfortable and made it really tricky
to hear others lines
can you imagine needing six people to
help you get out of your clothes so you
could go to the washroom
if not ask brie larson since this was
her reality filming captain marvel in
the skintight superhero getup
getting into this costume itself well
that just took two people in a full half
hour
and then there was the tight and
restrictive helmet composed of five
different pieces that all sort of
slotted together on her head not only
was she stuck wearing the extremely
uncomfortable costume for hours on end
she also had to fly in it painful much
the worst part is when is honestly is
getting an
itch because it's so thick have you ever
been on a 15-hour flight
if so you know it is super uncomfortable
and according to ant-man himself paul
rudd
that is exactly what wearing his costume
was like
the suit is skin tight thick and
extremely hot
especially when shooting in atlanta
georgia rudd admitted that one of the
worst parts of wearing the suit was when
he had an itch that needed scratching
the suit made it impossible so he
resorted to literally having people
on set punch the itchy spots in hopes of
deterring the discomfort
it looks like he could still enjoy
himself through the pain though when i
had that the audition had no idea how
big the character would be palm
clementiev had to spend a crazy three
hours in the makeup chair each day she
was shooting to transform into mantis
on top of that clementev said keeping a
straight face in the makeup chair was
super challenging as well
so how exactly did they accomplish this
exotic look small prosthetics at the top
of her forehead acted as marks for her
antennae and her bug-like eyes were
courtesy of huge black contacts
it looks cool but she was left feeling
super claustrophobic and uncomfortable
because of them
we do this great black war paint it's
like a tar
painted across my face ronin the accuser
looks incredible on screen
but how much work went into bringing him
to life well
lee pace spent countless hours sitting
in the makeup chair being painted a
periwinkle color
having veins painted in and of course
these
thick black bits on his face pace
described it like having tar on your
face
which doesn't make the whole acting
thing easy it was so painful and
restrictive his face couldn't move
naturally at all while it felt so stiff
and heavy
on top of all that he had purple
contacts and a headdress
torture much even just to do this is
like
two pounds six pounds ten pounds
when michael chiklis took on the role of
the thing in the first two fantastic
four films
cgi wasn't quite as advanced as it is
now
so he wore a full suit made out of latex
and rubber
it took two hours to get the full
costume on prosthetic teeth included
when it came to performing chicklis
struggled with such a stiff costume that
made simple tasks like sitting or
picking up a bottle of water
extremely tough because whenever he
moved the suit would actually
tighten and tense up leaving him in
loads of pain
it was the hottest i've ever been
typically we hear about actors having to
get in shape for their marvel roles
but it was a totally different story for
chris hemsworth while he didn't gain
weight for his time as fat thor
he did carry around some extra weight an
insane
60 to 70 pounds to be exact oh yeah
that's just how much the prosthetics
weigh without armor
the suit limited how much he was able to
move and was generally extremely
uncomfortable
and super hot and i was like all swollen
underneath the makeup then it was
turns out a trip to hawkins isn't all
sunshine and daisies
both on screen and behind the scenes
stranger things has had their fair share
of goriness
and horror over the past three seasons
and while we may think
it looked epic on screen it's at the
expense of the cast
suffering through just as many hours in
the makeup department
as they do on set it's time to find out
just what would make the stranger things
cast
want to trade a day in prosthetics for a
trip to the upside down instead
i've been waiting to meet this king
steve everybody's been telling me
so much about both billy hargrove and
daker montgomery were put through the
ringer in season three
just in different ways with the mind
flayer on the loose and getting mixed
up with billy it resulted in plenty of
wounds wounds that were all created by
the makeup and special effects
department
there was no cgi or vfx for this
character
daker spent hours on end in the makeup
chair before heading to set each day
and when billy was at his worst daker
was sporting 33 prosthetics
at once 33. between him and his stunt
double the makeup team had to create and
apply
99 prosthetics in one day he was wearing
so much glue that during one of his
lunch breaks his arm prosthetics got
stuck to the tablecloth
what made things even worse is millie
bobby brown's knee injury actually
caused the filming of daker scenes to be
pushed up with barely any notice
the makeup department head amy l
forsythe said i got a call during the
hiatus giving me a heads up about doing
the post sauna scene with billy
on the stairwell getting his wounds
nursed the day after we were to get back
from hiatus
i hadn't even seen a preview for the
sauna fight so i didn't know how he was
getting hurt or where his wounds might
be
i gotta warn you again in your band for
life the duffer brothers were super
adamant about including as many
practical effects as they could in
stranger things which means season one
barely required
any digital visual effects including the
demogorgon
the demogorgon was actually just one big
prosthetic suit that was worn by actor
mark steger
however opting for practical effects
came with some pretty big challenges for
mark
he had to perform some intense stunts in
the suit that he couldn't properly hear
or
see in but he did say that it helped him
remember why he loved film
in the later seasons the duffer brothers
eventually decided to move on to more of
a cgi route
let's just say things got a little too
gooey
it's crazy this is crazy this is crazy
daker loved being able to embrace billy
by adding on his
bad boy characteristics like his tattoo
and scar
however it was at the expense of
spending more time in the makeup chair
after a full day of filming daker would
endure another two hours removing the
prosthetics from his body
including the prosthetics he needed to
cover his facial hair shadow
he wore the prosthetic so much that at
one point he noticed his body hair
wasn't even growing
back anymore every day when you spend
like two hours getting them off
like i remember there was a big cut and
scar right here
you can see i've got no hair on my arm
there because it's just been months and
months of shaving right in that spot
it shouldn't have looked for me as much
as we all love steve harrington now
there was a time where him getting beat
up wasn't something we felt bad about
but you might feel bad for joe kiri when
you hear what he had to go through while
wearing these prosthetics
not only was joe sick on the day they
shot these scenes but he had to have
menthol blown in his eyes to achieve the
desired effects
ouch to be specific amy shared that his
prosthetics included a swollen jaw lump
cut split lip and a mixture of cotton
and dried blood
she shared her process on instagram and
even called joe a trooper
ahoy ladies i didn't see you there
will's possession scene took a major
toll on noah schnapp both mentally and
physically
not only did he have to put himself in a
dark place but his costume consisted of
black contacts that made his eyes
burn his costume was also not designed
for the weather
although it may have looked like it was
warm on screen noah explains it was
filmed in the middle of winter
there was just so much going on the
heaters didn't actually heat up
it wasn't really hot it was actually
really cold because it was winter
the cherry on top of it all was that
noah was so overworked and tired he woke
up the next day with no voice
i was screaming the whole night and the
next morning i woke up and my voice had
disappeared
movie makeup doesn't always mean gory
wounds and scars
sometimes the actors have a difficult
time wearing foundation
heaps of it nancy never really found
herself in a situation that led to an
injury but she did spend hours each day
in the makeup chair
it may not seem like it but natalie dyer
says she wore
so much makeup on set that she began
suffering from acne
the only solution was for her to amp up
her skincare game to prevent it from
getting any worse
we asked for forgiveness not permission
what the audience doesn't realize is
that prosthetics can sometimes minimize
an actor's senses
in this intense shower scene that daker
had to film he was so
physically involved that he was actually
injured without even realizing
he was only able to see the scrapes and
bruises that he accumulated on his body
after taking off the prosthetics he was
wearing just listen to him
explain his experience i was covered
head to toe and cuts and bruises and i
took all the skin off the top of my toes
and
one of stranger things goriest scenes
had to be when a mind flayer
literally hatches from eleven's leg
while the mind flayer in this scene was
digitally added in post-production
everything else about the wound was done
using makeup and prosthetics
millie had the benefit of using a
prosthetic leg instead of her own
however it was still pretty gross to
work with but not gross enough to stop
her from taking an instagram selfie with
it
it took months of research from the
makeup department in order to make the
leg and wound look as realistic as
possible
and it's safe to say they did a duffer
brother approved job
i could do it who knew how versatile lip
gloss could be
billy's flayed look was achieved by
applying layers and layers of mac clear
lip gloss
all in all he had to wear a layer of lip
gloss a layer of dirt and mud
and then another layer of lip gloss to
seal it all together
as you can imagine wearing lip gloss
wasn't the most comfortable experience
but daker said it worked better in the
scene that he wasn't constantly having
to be sprayed with water all day to
achieve the wet look
just look how big that lip gloss jar is
one of the things we've gathered from
going behind the scenes of stranger
things
is that millie bobby brown gives her all
into her character 11.
no matter the circumstances
filming her scenes in the voyage shook
her to her core literally
her wardrobe was not cut out for how
cold it was on set that day
especially because she was constantly
working with water the stranger things
art director said
the one thing you are missing is that it
was freezing cold on stage that day we
shot this
and millie was a real trooper splashing
around in the cold water
sfx tried to heat it but it was too
shallow to retain
any heat don't be afraid don't be afraid
don't be afraid
when you think about who the duffer
brothers were inspired by steven
spielberg
stephen king and john carpenter it's no
surprise they went down the practical
effects route even if it was
uncomfortable for the stranger things
cast at times
in addition to all the prosthetics and
makeup they even used practical effects
to create
a lot of the upside down set and brutal
battle scenes like bob's demise
did we mention that will's body double
was so realistically made by the makeup
department that they were able to pull
off the ultimate prank on noah schnapp's
mom
the question is what's worse wearing
prosthetics and makeup
or fighting demogorgons after hearing
about how barb's actress shannon purser
had to eat baby food for her pool scene
and bob's actor sean astin had to
continuously put fake blood in his mouth
we're going with demogorgons all jokes
aside the stranger things cast
truly does give their all into every
single episode they film
and these behind-the-scenes moments
spell it out perfectly
which actor do you think had it worse
when it came to special effects
let us know below thanks for watching